ADAM MARTIN: So to
start out, I just
wanted to mention we talk a
lot about dogma in the lab.
So we talk about dogma, right?
There's the central
dogma, which is DNA.
Information flows from
DNA to RNA to protein.
I'm going to describe
another dogma, if you will,
which is that life starts
as sort of a fertilized egg.
So you get a fertilized egg.
And this fertilized egg, which
you see in the video up here,
undergoes development.
And as part of that
development there
is what is known
as differentiation,
where cells acquire more
specialized cell types.
So there's development
and differentiation.
And this results in
adult cell types that
are known as differentiated.
So it results in
differentiated/adult cell types
with specialized functions.
And you see just a few of
them up on the slide above.
There are, in fact, thousands
of different sort of cell types
that humans have.
But the dogma, at least
up until fairly recently--
in the past couple of decades
or so or at least before 1960,
1950s--
is that this is
you unidirectional,
that basically the development
goes in one direction, where
you go from the fertilized egg
to the differentiated adult
cell types.
And so this state down here--
the differentiated adult cell
types are fairly stable, right?
I mean, if you look
at your neighbor
you see they don't
have muscle growing
on the outside of their bodies.
Their skin cells
stay skin cells.
And that is a
relatively stable state.
OK.
Now, last week you learned
about a contradiction
to the central dogma, which is
the behavior of retroviruses,
which have reverse
transcriptase, which
can sort of go backwards up this
pathway, where you can get DNA
from RNA.
OK.
And today, we're going
to talk about how
you can sort of overcome this
you unidirectional path here.
And this is going to be what
we will call reprogramming.
But first, I want to talk about
this differentiation process
because it's important
for us to understand this
before we get into the
reprogramming event.
And so the fertilized egg
is capable of producing all
of these different cell types.
OK.
So the fertilized egg will
be known as totipotent,
meaning it has the potential
to form all cell types.
And then over
development, this potency
goes down such that
when cells differentiate
into their final
adult form there
is a much more limited
repertoire of cell types
that the cell can go into.
And one way of
thinking about this
is that if you think of
this marble run here,
the totipotent state is
right at the top here, right?
If I put a marble
in the top here,
it has the potential of
going into any of these three
sort of different fates.
OK.
So this is the totipotent
state up at the top.
And you'll see
these marbles will
be able to go into any of these
three different states here.
OK.
But you see how that marble
went down on this path.
Some marbles go
down in this path.
And so you can think of cells
going through development
is sort of getting funneled
into these distinct paths.
And in this case,
it's kind of random.
But in development,
it relies on signaling
between cells and
interaction between cells
in the multicellular organism.
So as an example,
I want to tell you
about early
mammalian development
and the differentiation
of cell types
in the early mammalian embryo.
OK.
So we start with an oocyte.
That's the female gamete.
And the male gamete, the sperm.
So these can come together
to form the zygote.
If I draw a little circle in
the middle, it's a nucleus.
And this zygote is totipotent.
And the embryo undergoes
cleavage divisions,
which I'll show here.
You see how that zygote
divided into two cells.
Now it's going to
divide into four.
And it'll keep dividing
till it's 16 probably.
So you get cleavage
divisions that
generate more than one cell.
You start with a single cell.
The cleavage divisions give
you more than one cell.
And what you see up
here now is a stage
known as the blastocyst
or the blastula.
You can see there's a hollow
sort of inner fluid-filled area
here.
And you see there
are cells around
that fluid-filled cavity.
And there's a thickening
on one side of the embryo.
OK.
So I'm going to
draw that out here.
Sorry.
Mine is a little flat up here.
It should be
perfectly spherical.
And there is this thickening on
one side of the blastula, which
is a bunch of cells that
are kind of interior
on the inside of the embryo.
These cells on the interior are
known as the inner cell mass.
And these cells
are now restricted
in what they can become.
These cells will become
the embryo proper.
So they'll become
the cell types that
will be a part of the fetus.
These cells on the outside are
known as the trophoblast cells.
And these cells will form
part of the placenta--
the embryonic portion
of the placenta.
So they form part
And they're important
for this embryo
being able to implant
into the uterine wall.
So if we think about--
this is the first example
of differentiation in the
early mammalian embryo
because you can see,
based on what I said here,
these cells are
becoming restricted
in what they can become.
So this is kind of
like the first branch
point in differentiation.
So we get some more
marbles going down here.
All right.
So this would be the
sort of stage right
before the blastula,
before differentiation.
And you can see these marbles--
when I let them, they
will either go this way
and become one fate, or
they'll go the other way
and be sort of directed
down another potential fate.
There we go.
So this is the first sort of
branch point, if you will,
in fate determination
for the mammalian embryo.
And so this branch point
here is different from this
because once the marble
goes one way or the other,
it's restricted in what
fate it can become.
OK.
So these cells here
are not totipotent
because they can't
form the trophoblast.
They can't form the part of the
placenta needed by the embryo.
But they do form
the embryo proper.
So they are still
capable of many fates.
And so these cells are
known as pluripotent, which
means capable of many things
OK.
And so a type of
cell type, which
I'm sure you've heard about,
is called Embryonic Stem cells,
or ES cells.
These ES cells are derived
from the inner cell mass.
So these would be--
if they were taken
out of the blastula--
sorry-- this is
called the blastula--
if they are taken from the
blastula and cultured in vitro,
these would be sort of
embryonic stem cells
that can be propagated.
And they form the embryo proper,
so these are pluripotent stem
cells that can basically-- they
are still capable of forming
sort of any of the cell
types in the embryo--
capable of forming
embryonic cell types.
Now let's look at
the next slide.
So this branch point--
this first branch point
sort of in development
is associated with changes
in gene expression.
So there are changes
And you're seeing one
up on the slide above.
The slide above is
a fixed blastula.
And all of the nuclei
in the blastula
are stained with green.
But there is one gene
that's stained in red.
It's called Oct4.
And this is a
transcription factor that
marks sort of pluripotency.
And you can see how it's
expressed specifically
in these cells of the
inner cell mass, which
are what the embryonic stem
cells are derived from.
So there are clearly
changes in gene expression.
And one question you might
have is whether or not
these cells that are going
to form the embryo proper,
whether they have lost
information such that they're
unable to form the
part of the placenta.
And you can also ask
this for an adult cell.
Has an adult cell in your body--
has it lost gene content such
that it's unable to
make an entire organism?
I'm going to tell
you the answer.
I want you to think
about what experiment
would allow you to sort
of determine the answer.
But I'm going to tell you the
answer is that there is not
a loss of gene content.
But this differentiation
process is
due to changes in
gene expression
for the vast majority
of our cell types.
So let's say you wanted to
determine whether or not
a differentiated cell had
lost some sort of capability
to regenerate an
entire organism.
What might be some type of
experiment you could do?
Brett.
AUDIENCE: Creating
conditions that will perhaps
be similar to what embryonic
stem cells or perhaps
[INAUDIBLE] factors that
allow for you to change
the expression back to
more than one impact
to see if that would
actually change it.
ADAM MARTIN: All right.
Great.
So Brett had two really
good points, I think.
The first is to try to sort
of reproduce conditions
of pluripotency.
Or you can even try to reproduce
conditions of totipotency,
right?
In which case you'd
want to sort of take
the genetic material
of the somatic cell
and sort of put it back
in this situation where
it's present sort of in the
cytoplasm of the zygote.
And the other point
that Brett made
is to try to maybe express
something that would induce
this type of pluripotent state.
If we knew exactly
what the genes were
that create this
pluripotent state,
maybe we could just
express those genes
and regenerate
sort of a cell that
moves from way down here all
the way up to the top again.
And, actually, what
Brett suggested
were the two experiments that
won these two folks the Nobel
Prize in 2012.
So in 2012, the Nobel
Prize was awarded jointly
to Sir John Gurdon, right
here, who incidentally
has the best hair of all
Nobel laureates, and also
Shinya Yamanaka.
And so these two folks were
awarded the Nobel Prize
for being able to show that
mature differentiated cells can
be reprogrammed to
become pluripotent again,
which basically gives us the
conclusion that there's not
a loss of gene content during
the differentiation process.
And the work from
Yamanaka showed us
several genes whose expression
is critical to induce
this type of reprogramming.
And their work
spanned from frogs--
so John Gurdon worked
on development of frogs,
specifically Xenopus laevis,
which you've seen before.
Shinya Yamanaka's work involved
mice and also human cell lines.
So I'm going to tell you
about their experiments
and how this-- sort of
demonstrated this conclusion
here.
And the first thing
I want to show you
is an experiment, which is
very simple conceptually.
Technically it's very
complicated, which
is if you were able to take
a nucleus from an adult cell
that's differentiated,
could you get
it to change by introducing
it back into the egg
cell or a zygote cell?
So this experiment
involves having an oocyte,
but in this case an oocyte where
the nucleus has been removed.
So you take an
enucleated oocyte.
And want to know if the
cytoplasm of this oocyte
is somehow special
that would allow
it to reprogram the nucleus
of a differentiated cell.
And so you could
suck up the nucleus
of a differentiated cell.
So a somatic cell is another
way to say differentiated.
So it's a somatic cell nucleus.
And the experiment
conceptually then
is to just take this somatic
cell nucleus that you've
sucked up and inject it into
an oocyte without a nucleus
and see if the
cytoplasm of this oocyte
is somehow able to change
the properties of the nucleus
such that it now is in an
undifferentiated state.
So you generate oocyte now
with the somatic cell nucleus.
And the question is whether
the somatic cell nucleus
is capable of generating
the diversity of cell types
that are normally
present in an organism.
So you could then let
this go and develop.
You could let it develop
into a blastula, which
I'm drawing here.
So you could
generate a blastula.
And this will be a way to get
embryonic stem cells derived
from sort of this
type of nucleus.
But you could also let it
grow into an entire organism.
But this organism
would be genetically
identical to whatever
organism donated this nucleus.
So because you're
duplicating an organism,
that is known as
reproductive cloning.
So this is reproductive
cloning, if you
go all the way to the organism.
I'll show you just a little
video on the nuclear transfer.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- You see now that this drilling
pipe head is going to suck--
drill a little hole
into the membrane.
You can maybe see a little
bit of the hole right
here at the next part.
[END PLAYBACK]
ADAM MARTIN: He's talking
about this pipette here.
The embryo is being held with
another pipette over here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- You can see a bit of the hole.
And now the pipette's going to
go in and remove the nucleus.
And if you look
carefully in the pipette,
you'll see a line in
the nucleus, which are
all the chromosomes lined up.
So the nucleus is going to be
squirted out now because we
don't need it anymore.
And then we have
an enucleated egg.
Now, the next step is to take
a set of eggs like that--
and I'll show you two--
and then transfer
into them a nucleus
from another kind of cell, a
fully-differentiated somatic
cell.
So here, the enucleated
egg is set on the side.
And it's held by this
holding pipette on the left.
There's drilling the little
hole in the membrane.
Here we go in.
Here comes the nucleus
from the right.
[END PLAYBACK]
ADAM MARTIN: That's
from a somatic zone.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- And these pipettes
are operated
with a piezoelectric device.
So you can't see
it here, but it's
like a little jackhammer
going very quickly,
(TRILLING SOUND) like Woody the
Woodpecker, getting in there.
[END PLAYBACK]
ADAM MARTIN: I don't
know if I would
have used Woody the
Woodpecker as an analogy,
but that's basically the idea.
So you can take a nucleus
from a somatic cell
and transplant it, if you
will, into an oocyte and then
determine whether you
can get either a blastula
or an entire organism from that
differentiated cell's nucleus.
So this is one result
from Sir John Gurdon.
And what the experiment
was, in this case,
was to take oocytes, or eggs,
from this wild-type laevis frog
and to transplant nuclei from
donor frogs that are albino.
So you can see this is an
elegant experiment in that you
can sort of track the
origin of the nucleus,
because it's genetically
marked with this albino sort
of phenotype.
So you're getting
a nuclei from--
you're getting nuclei
from albino tadpoles.
So these are
differentiated cell nuclei.
And they're transplanted
into wild-type donor eggs.
So normally, the
wild-type frog would
reproduce frogs that look
like it-- that are non-albino.
But in this experiment,
Gurdon and his lab
were able to get frogs
that were albino.
So these would be sort of clones
of whatever albino tadpoles
they got the nuclei from.
So you see, in this case, it's
the origin of the nucleus that
is determining sort of the
phenotype of these frogs.
So that allowed them to show
that the nucleus is getting
reprogrammed from
this albino tadpole
and is able to still generate
all of the cell types
present in a normal organism.
Yes.
Brett.
AUDIENCE: So this is
an unfertilized egg
that they were taking from the--
ADAM MARTIN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And so they're
extracting all this DNA,
then putting in a full set
of DNA from the albinos.
ADAM MARTIN: Yep.
AUDIENCE: It would go
on to differentiate
a full set of DNA?
ADAM MARTIN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So, yeah, they're--
and actually,
it was taking unfertilized eggs,
which is the biggest trick.
I think people had tried
to do this in frogs before,
and it failed because they
were using fertilized eggs.
And there's something about sort
of the oocyte development that
makes it better at
reprogramming the nucleus.
OK.
So that's with frogs.
So that experiment was actually
done in the late 1950s,
published in the early 1960s.
And so it took another 40 years
or so for the first mammal
to be cloned.
And you guys probably
weren't even born yet.
But for those of
us who are older,
we remember this
because there was
a big brouhaha over
Dolly the sheep, which
was the first cloned mammal.
I believe that's Dolly there.
So this is--
I'm not sure which one is Dolly.
They're both the
same type of sheep.
So this was done by Ian
Wilmut and his group.
One thing I want to
point out about this
is it's incredibly inefficient.
If you look over
here, this Dolly
resulted from over
400 oocytes having
this sort of nuclear
transplant take place.
So it's not a very
efficient process.
And so that lack of
efficiency is due to the fact
that the nucleus is resisting
getting reprogrammed.
And this is a graph from one
of John Gurdon's sort of--
he wrote a review article
on sort of reprogramming
after he won the Nobel Prize.
This is from that.
And what's plotted is
sort of the frequency
in which transfers
results in sort
of a differentiated organism.
And what's on the
x-axis is the stage
of the cell that's
used to transplant.
And so what you see is that over
the course of differentiation
it gets harder and
harder for the nucleus
to get reprogrammed to create
sort of all the cell types that
are normally present
in an adult animal.
So nuclei do become
more restricted
in their ability to be
reprogrammed over development.
But the fact that any of them
are able to be reprogrammed
suggests that when they are--
that during
differentiation there
is not a loss of gene content.
And John Gurdon has done
a lot to characterize
sort of the changes
in the nucleus that
happen during differentiation
which sort of resist
this reprogramming by
the oocyte cytoplasm.
All right.
So mechanistically,
what's happening?
Well, one big--
one of the people
who really showed what's going
on there is Shinya Yamanaka.
And what his work shows is that
you can take just a few genes--
it turns out it is four--
and you can induce
reprogramming by just
expressing these four genes in
an adult differentiated cell.
So in this case you have
a differentiated cell.
And what he initially used
we're fibroblasts, which are
a type of differentiated cell.
And what Yamanaka
showed is that you
can express four
transcription factors, one
of them being this
factor here, Oct4,
which is expressed in
the inner cell mass
and was shown to
be involved in sort
of maintaining pluripotency of
these inner cell mass cells.
So you could take Oct4 plus
another transcription factor,
which is important for
pluripotency, plus two
others and c-Myc.
These are the four.
So these are all
transcription factors.
And what they found is
if you express these four
transcription factors in
a differentiated cell,
you could get it to revert
to a more pluripotent state.
So this results in what is known
as Induced Pluripotent Stem
cells, or IPS cells, for short.
And then like
embryonic stem cells,
here these cells can give
rise to different cell types.
And so one of the goals of this
field of developmental biology
and cell reprogramming
is to use this technology
to replace cells that
are lost in patients.
So this is known as
regenerative medicine.
And the idea of the theory
of regenerative medicine
is to take ES cells or
induced pluripotent stem
cells from patients and to be
able to culture them in vitro--
so culture in vitro--
and then to be able to
direct these cultured cells
into different
cell fates in order
to use these cells possibly
to transplant them back
into an individual where maybe
these cell types are dying.
So you could then
differentiate these cells using
certain biochemical signals
that you can add to the media
in order to create
different cell types,
like neurons,
muscle, maybe skin.
And one example of this was
shown by Shinya Yamanaka, where
what they did was to take
human fibroblast cells,
put them back in the
pluripotent state
by expressing
those four factors,
and then get these
cells to differentiate
into cardiac tissue,
so cardiac cells.
Here's a movie.
So these are from
adult fibroblast cells.
But now you can see
they're beating sort
of like a cardiac tissue would.
So these were made into IPS
stem cells, cultured in vitro,
and then directed into
a cardiac muscle fate.
So the goal would
then to be use these
and to transplant them
back into a patient, such
that if a patient
had, let's say,
a neurodegenerative
disease and was lacking
a certain type of
neuron, you could then
take cells, start them on the
path to neuronal development,
and then transplant them
back into that patient.
And if these cells are derived
from the DNA of that patient,
then there won't be
transplant rejection.
Because what regulates
transplant rejection
is the major histocompatiblity
complex locus.
And it's polymorphic.
But if you're taking a
nucleus from the patient
and then causing the cells
to differentiate in vitro,
you're taking the exact same--
you're taking clonal cells
and putting them back
in the same patient,
such that they
won't be rejected, ideally.
All right.
Now I want to try something
with the remainder of our time.
I want a group--
all right.
Everyone on this
side of the room
over, I want you over here.
And everyone on this
side of the room,
I want you on this
side over here.
OK.
Maybe you guys can go over here
so that we're more balanced.
We're going to have
a little debate.
You can sit down.
It's OK.
Be in a position to
talk to each other.
I want you guys
talking to each other.
That was the goal of
putting you close together.
OK.
So in the past
couple weeks, there's
been a little bit of
a stir because there's
a researcher in China who
has claimed to have made
the first gene-edited baby.
Perhaps you have heard of this.
You probably have because
it's been all over the news.
So I want you guys--
let's see.
I want us to debate
whether we should--
what are the advantages
or disadvantages
of gene editing
or human cloning.
You could talk about both.
And then I want you guys to
be able to present them to me.
I'll write them down, and we'll
have a discussion about it.
Guys, continue this discussion
sort of outside class.
I think it's really interesting.
And it's going to be
something that you're
going to hear a lot about in
the coming years, I'm sure.